and minim wrists he hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcomes episode 133 today
we're gonna talk about constrains now I
was talking to that way brought all
these handcuffs I was talking about this
weekend she said the same thing she's
like he's like handcuffs like yeah I'm
like no that's restraint
no those are restraint so maybe we'll do
an episode on restraint in the future
but right now we're gonna talk about
constraints and while we're here before
we dive into these questions Ryan let's
talk about some useful constraints in in
our life some things that really came to
mind right away as I started preparing
for this episode our last documentary
was certainly constrained but it bred a
particular kind of creativity we didn't
have a million dollar budget or I guess
movies now have 100 million dollar
budgets we had a zero dollar budget
during the filming I don't know if it
would have been any better if we had one
hundred million dollar budget and one
could argue it would be worse and you
know if you go back David Foster Wallace
wrote a great essay about Terminator 2
and how it basically couldn't hold a
candle to Terminator 1 and he gave a
really good argument why it didn't but
essentially what it came down to is
James Cameron is a genius and he was
constrained with that first we didn't
have a huge budget so we had to do
certain things with lighting and
atmospherics that a person with a
gigantic budget to do special effects
all this other stuff wouldn't have to do
so he made this ominous dark movie part
of that was almost by accident or
because of not by accident but because
of the constraints he worked with what
he had and those constraints made the
film better and I think about our
documentary when it was like okay we're
already on the road so we're not gonna
pay for all this travels so in 2014 when
we filmed this it was like okay what
cities that were going to and who in
those cities can we interview because we
can't afford to fly to Egypt to
interview someone we can't afford to fly
to Wichita to interview someone so one
of the cities we're going to be in let's
find the appropriate people to talk to
while we are there
we just happened to find 2530 people and
half of which made it into the
documentary and and what I realized is
like the only money we spent on on that
film the only the only costs for the
film were post-production the filming
itself didn't really cost us anything
because we brought Matt on the road with
us and he already had the camera
equipment that was necessary for the
filming and so you're right man had we
had a million dollars or ten million
dollars we do with I don't know even if
we flew to Egypt I don't even know
someone in Egypt we would have
interviewed now here's the thing we may
have found you stumbled across someone
and so the only thing I think we could
have done better with a documentary even
though it's an outstanding documentary
we could have just dove a little bit
deeper into some of the environmental
stuff with fast fat with fast fashion we
could have maybe dove a little bit
deeper into like the architecture and
certain pieces of the documentary that
if we have the budget for we could have
you know flown out and got those those
bits of those extra bits that might dive
a little bit deeper but two things a the
documentary is awesome like I'm really
proud of it yeah so I'm not like sitting
here saying oh I wish we did more I'm
saying could we have done more sure
there's always going to be something we
could do better with the creation that
we made right right
the second thing too is that we can
still dive deeper we don't we know how
we didn't have to do in that last
documentary and we are we are totally
planning to dive a little bit deeper
with some stuff that we have planned in
the future right so even though maybe we
don't have that for that last
documentary it's still okay yeah well I
think you can't you can never create
this infinitely dense thing where it's
like I want to include everything that I
have ever known and everything I could
possibly talk about and also have
rebuttals to every potential argument
that all critics are going to have and
by the way it has to fit inside this
nice neat 79 minute narrative that
that's simply not possible until you
realize and that's another constraint
having just an hour hour and a half as a
particular kind of constraint there's a
reason that TED talks are 18 minutes or
less is because you constrain yourself
to that timeframe you can't talk about
everything you have to get into the
point allows you to dive deep enough
into the point that hopefully someone
wants more and they do their own
research
to dive deep exactly yeah and and so or
if you have someone like Derek severs
who we had on the podcast recently he
has three TED talks all of which I
believe are three minutes each yeah and
and that's one of the ultimate
constraint where he knows I can't talk
about 99.99999% of everything I'd like
to talk about so what is the one idea I
want people to walk away from this talk
or this podcast or this book or this
blog post with by the way the
documentary we're talking about for
those of you are new for some reason
it's just called minimalism and you can
find it on Netflix or wherever you find
documentaries if if you haven't seen our
documentary yet and I think the same is
is true with books I mean I didn't have
any budget for writing books you and I
when we were our second book my favorite
book the thing that we created
everything that remains we moved to a
cabin in little nowhere I talked about
about constraints like all you have is
time to write pretty much write the the
nearby town is population 870 or 820 and
and and there's one traffic light in
thirty four hundred square miles so
maybe you go grocery shopping once a
week or every other week sometimes yeah
otherwise you you have this constraint
of these four walls and your creativity
mm-hm and so quite often the constraints
that that we often get pissed off about
why why don't I have more money more
time more whatever why don't I have more
more more and more and more and more
because sometimes that more isn't gonna
serve you in fact sometimes that more is
going to get in the way of what you're
trying to do if it's especially if
you're trying to create something or do
something that is meaningful
sometimes those constraints can guide
you yeah absolutely no it's funny how I
think about a life with no constraints
and when I when I imagine people who
I've ran into throughout my almost 37
years of existence the people with no
constraints are sometimes like the least
happiest yeah and and I don't know why
that is maybe because when you have no
constraints you expect things to be
really easy and the life is not easy and
never will be easy
well they say going with the flow and
the sounds great
a while until you end up at some Rapids
without a paddle and without a plan and
then that's when you're in for a world
of hurt I mean did you I think of
children you know they need to be
constrained otherwise they they run wild
we're gonna watch that video this
weekend yeah yeah I want to go do hood
rat stuff with my friends like the
little seven-year-old kid driving his
grandma's car and crashing into a bunch
of stuff that's kind of what we do but
sort of just in in a more adult way or
at least ostensibly adult way yeah I was
just as funny as you were saying that I
was just thinking about it an
unconstrained child and what does an
unconstraint child look like yes he's
driving around his grandma's car at 7
years old with his friend doing hood rat
things I'm quoting him by the way that
the news anchor said don't you realize
you could have killed some people and he
said yeah but I wanted to do hood rat
stuff of my friend and and that's sort
of what we're doing right now we're
wasting our time in fact I'm gonna do
this right now since we when we travel I
put email and Instagram and Twitter back
on my phone while we're traveling so I
don't always have to carry my computer
with me and but when when we're not
traveling which we're back we we were
just in Joshua Tree this weekend working
on the second documentary which is full
of all kinds of constraints
although we have fewer constraints now
although were sort of self imposing some
constraints so we have some
opportunities to instead of just going
the route we went before we like to do
stuff ourselves to partner up with a
major studio and do something like that
in fact we've had several people try to
talk us into going that route and
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that but for us we wanted the constraint
of let's do this ourselves so that we'll
have other people telling us what to do
with that promotes interesting when we
were in Joshua Tree Matt he was talking
about oh man maybe we could do this one
scene you know we would have to like you
know have a bigger budget for it and
when we were talking about it it was
like oh wow like putting this one scene
renting out the space and and getting
the the the the location ready for us to
film would almost could possibly double
our budget yeah and for two minutes
scene for two minutes scene and the
question is is you know would that scene
really add that much value to the
documentary maybe maybe not right but I
mean all three of us kind of looked at
each other like wait a minute yeah
like that's kind of silly yeah we got to
like stick to the basics here right
stick to what we know and throwing you
know more money at this documentary is
it necessarily what's gonna make it
better right and so the second
documentary is called the minimalists
less is now and it's around this talk
Ron and I gave this talk 50 times last
in the last year we did a 50 city tour
and we sort of refined the talk on
different stages and so we went film
that talk and it's 40 minutes plus other
words what we got it down to and then
we're building the next documentary
around that talk and that in and of
itself is sort of a constraint because
you're constrained to the what is
already there like what's the format of
this thing but then also how do we
expand beyond because we don't want it
to just be a 40-minute talk like that
would be fine that'd be one thing but
this is also it's a half documentary
half special so you're you're sort of
within the constraints of a format or
maybe sometimes you break out outside of
the restraints of the format and and you
you you go ten percent farther to to
create your own thing and that's where
originality and and the uniqueness comes
from is you use those constraints to
your advantage and sometimes you're like
well I need to break free of that now
that that scene you're talking about
recording a a two-minute scene and
doubling the budget of the film would
that be worth it probably not but then
the question becomes given the
constraints we have if we can't afford
to spend $30,000 on a two-minute scene
then what what do we do can we still do
it and make it meaningful and and it
maybe just maybe it becomes more
meaningful because we have the
constraints to to we have to work within
these constraints so we have to get more
creative in order for it to work yeah
because sometimes what happens people
just throw money at the problem and
money won't solve your problems it'll
solve your money problems but it's not
gonna solve your creativity problems
it's not gonna solve your relationship
problems I know that the number one
the couples fight about a sex and then
money is second right well it's not
gonna solve your sex problems lucky'
it's not even gonna solve your
relationship problems that are masked as
money problems right because guess what
there are plenty of people who are
millionaires who still have fights about
money in fact they're probably more
people on average as a percentage that
have fights about money because they
have excess right and everyone wants a
piece of their money oh so anyway what
I'm gonna do right now is add a
constraint to myself I'm going to my
phone and deleting Instagram and my
email and Twitter a little into your
email what can you delete your email on
your phone yeah absolutely just by
holding it down yes just hold it down
until it submits Ryan oh my reach in
that email my mind has just been blown
[Music]
[Laughter]
so I just deleted my Twitter and my
Instagram I still interact on these
platforms don't get me wrong I just
don't like having them on my phone now
Ryan let's talk about why I don't like
having those on my phone because for me
they become that they become an easy-out
they can become an easy go-to they
become a pacifier for me and they
actually get in the way they prevent me
from creating because when there's a
time where I'm like I should be writing
this morning oh I will let me just check
Instagram real quick I'll pull out my
phone starts checking no no for me I in
order for me to have good habits in my
life I often have to have my
self-imposed constraints I don't want
other people necessarily putting the the
constraints on my life that's sort of
totalitarian I'm not into that but what
I'm into is defining the limitations
that work best for me and quite often I
know if I'm grasping for something like
twitching for something is a better work
if I'm twitching for it maybe I should
remove it from my life for a period of
time in fact once I have Twitter off my
phone actually enjoy it a lot more
because now when I go to I go to it with
intention I want to sit down I'm gonna
spend half an hour replying to tweets
and looking at other people's tweets and
checking some articles and it's with
intention it's not just the the constant
scrolling you know they say the
scrolling is the new smoking that we put
out on the website that's really the
place where I've gotten we
a lot of my technology is I've treated
it like it's an impulse right yeah so
it's easy to do I've removed that before
we get in these questions I also wanted
to talk to you about this this little
cartoon I had I was wondering what that
cartoon was over there I was gonna ask
you but I was like oh maybe it's for the
added value portion I won't ruin it so
no in the mornings I I generally like
the right exercise and read but I've
moved a lot of my reading to nighttime
now that way I could just do two things
the morning I'm exercising and I'm
writing but when I'm reading sometimes I
read The New Yorker because they have
some good fiction in there but also some
other good journalism and this was just
one of those cartoons from The New
Yorker and it's a lady at a birthday
party and she's got this big smile on
her face and she's saying thank you so
much there's presents all over the table
birthday presents right
there's thank you so much I'll keep this
in my special box of things I can't
throw away for fear of hurting someone's
feelings now obviously this episode has
nothing to do with gift-giving but to me
this was like this was the this we get
this question all the time a form of
this question or this statement where
it's like I'm holding on to something
because I'm afraid of hurting other
people's feelings well this well it
could go along with our podcast because
dude this is uh this is an example of
how this person and I used to be one of
those people who would not constrain
myself on getting gifts yeah I had no
constraints so then I had a bunch of
[ __ ] I didn't use right to to not offend
people who gave me the gifts but
ultimately I realized like when you're
honest with people they really don't
care what you they're your gifts you can
do what you want with them exactly and
in a weird way you're almost offending
yourself or you're offending your
sensibilities dude if I gave you
something and like you took it and you
were like oh thank you so much but then
like you went home and you like you went
to Baxter like man you know I really do
appreciate Ryan giving me this I'm
holding a coaster yeah I want a coaster
I mean I've been encrusted coast
we really appreciate Ryan giving me this
diamond-encrusted coaster but I really
am NOT gonna use this thing it's the
only coaster I own I'm certainly not
gonna just set it on my table to like if
it was causing you all this
stress right I would feel like a jerk if
you held on to it right well that's
because you are you're you're healthy
with respect to understanding other
people's needs there are some people who
will truly get their feelings hurt and
the here's the thing all you can't
control someone else's feelings you
can't control how someone else is going
to react and and so I mean I think this
response would be hilarious in fact I
might start using this if someone gives
me a gift am I saying
I'll keep this in my special box of
things I can't throw away because I'm
afraid of hurting other people's
feelings you're not a jerk like that
no well but but you just said like if
someone isn't being considerate maybe
I'm not the one being the jerk if
someone's giving me something I've
repeatedly asked them not to give me
who's the person who's being the juror
the person who's escalating the
situation but maybe the way to
deescalate I understand what you're
saying
Kafka said that the only way to deal
with life's most serious challenges is
through jokes and maybe if you have the
right person you can I mean I could say
this to you and it would be hilarity
funny yeah and and so my mama always
always told me too that just because
it's a joke doesn't mean it doesn't hurt
someone's feelings right and just
because a joke also doesn't mean it's
funny um but if you do want to hear more
about gift-giving we've done a couple
episodes about this we did one called
Easter although and it was just recently
it was episode 125 although it wasn't
just about Easter there's only one
question in there about Easter but we
talked about gift-giving and excess and
during the holidays right and another
one we did was called gift-giving yeah
episode 38 so episode 125 is Easter and
episode 38 is gift-giving if you want
some tips and tricks and advice for
gift-giving we answer some questions on
both of those episodes you can find
those over wherever you get podcasts
really
alright let's dive into these questions
come with you let's do it all right
first question is from Cheryl in Dallas
I'm 62 I'm from a small Texas town now
living in a major market city and work
in advertising in marketing after ending
a 30-year marriage and leaving a 4,500
square foot house I began to live on my
own
I've moved about six or seven times in
the last ten years with each move I've
gotten rid of more and more stuff about
a year ago I sold my house and gave away
almost everything I had to a nonprofit
that helps women who had to leave their
homes
suddenly due to domestic violence and
they have nothing to recreate a home for
themselves and their children furniture
dishes linens decor everything except my
grandson's stuff from their childhood
I'm now living in a one-bedroom
apartment with new and minimal furniture
dishes etc and I kind of like it
my question is coming from a mindset of
having plenty of room for the kids and
the grandkids to come home
things for the children to inherit plus
being a woman and having jewelry and
makeup and lots of shoes and all that
other fun stuff do you have advice for
someone like me do you have stories of
people of my generation and mindset as
they have minimum minimized
I'd like to have a tiny house but those
thing to be for people who don't have a
lot of clothes or business clothes or
makeup and they had the Attic ability to
make trips up and down a loft letter
several times a night I'm thinking a
thousand square feet is about as tiny as
I could get by with well Cheryl first of
all I think this and Ryan you tell me
what you think about this but I think
this proves that the things that used to
add value to Cheryl's life you know
using this 4,500 square foot house in a
a former life a former season of her
life with her former spouse those things
may have added value if you may have
gotten joy from them but she walked away
from them but someone else is actually
getting value from them now she's found
a way instead of storing them or
hoarding them or putting them in the
basement or trying to refill I think
consumerism is is a noxious gas of sorts
like it finds a way to fill whatever
space you have created for it right and
so if you have a 4,500 square foot house
it's all the stuff is were gonna own at
the Kanye West recently you know I'm
talking about me all the things so I saw
the interview the most impressive thing
for me is that he has this giant house
and he doesn't feel compelled to
with a bunch of stuff it looks empty
because I think that's the thing that
may it might call him his his some of
his was or whatever's going on in his
mind it's a way for him to calm the mind
no it certainly is for me a way to to
calm my mind regardless what you think
of Kanye West and many of the the rants
he's been going on now that that thing
was like it's a little throwaway thought
but I just looked at it I'm like oh like
there's no he is a massive house but
most people they get 4,500 square foot
out ten thousand square foot house
I must fill every nook and cranny right
because I'm constrained only by the
walls in my house yeah I've had I've had
mentoring students who they're like you
know I've got this big house and I've
got this big empty basement and you know
I just I've got some you know things
down there very similar to what to what
Cheryl was describing with memories and
with inheritance stuff and so forth and
so on and they're like you know is it
okay that I have this stuff stored like
first off I always say like yeah it's
you could do whatever you want you're an
adult it's okay to do whatever you want
as long as it's not you know imposing on
other people's rights um but but yes
yeah first and foremost yes you do have
permission but but second off let me ask
you if you didn't have that basement
would you be holding on all that stuff
oh no I probably wouldn't be holding on
to nearly as much of it yeah would you
go rent a storage locker and pay for the
additional space right and I the the the
the line from Cheryl's message that
stood out the most to me Ryan was her
voice
turned out that I could hear her smile
which tell me why she lives in the
one-bedroom house now and she goes I
kind of like it yeah
and that to me says it all right she's
like I've downsized I've let go I've
moved six or seven times I've gotten rid
of almost everything all the excess I've
let I've set down the baggage that I
once picked up right and she says and
you know what I kind of like it
and but now I'm looking at how do I go
even farther how do I have more of less
and and I don't see I could ever live in
a tiny house well you know what you
probably could but the question isn't
can you live in a tiny house you can
live on the street you can go camping
for the rest of your life you can do a
lot of things the question I think
is what is appropriate for your life
right now and maybe at 62 now that
you're in a big city in Dallas and a
thousand square feet is appropriate for
you I know me in my family we live in
about 900 square feet but it's it's a
really nice place it has everything we
need it's we have a bedroom and Ella has
a bedroom we have a living room we have
a small kitchen we have a bathroom
everything is fine for us it works
really well for us but what's
appropriate for me may not be
appropriate for you and so the question
then becomes what are the constraints
that you you can impose in your life
what were the edges for you right now
and maybe it's just putting constraints
closer to those edges so you can figure
out what is truly adding value to your
life and maybe what you can let go off
she talks she talks a little bit about
being a woman and having makeup and
clothes and shoes and stuff like that
you know this is anecdotal evidence from
Mariah obviously I don't have a bunch of
shoes and makeup and stuff but what I'll
say is over the five years that Mariah
and I have been together she has gone
out of her way to have the best curated
collection that she can of the things
that she mentioned their clothes shoes
makeup so so that Mariah when she goes
to her closet when she goes to her
makeup drawer when she goes to pull out
a pair of shoes like she knows that
she's going to grab something that she's
absolutely in love with so these were
constraints that I certainly have again
I've never I've said this a million
times I'll say two million times again I
have never asked Mariah to throw any
constraints on herself but what she has
realized is that when she does put
constraints on herself as specifically
with these items it's much easier to
make decisions when she's getting ready
to go out when when she's uh getting
ready in the mornings but you know the
other thing is Cheryl asked for two of
stories about people maybe her age who
were going through the same thing and
due to made me think about I forget what
city we were in but there was this older
couple elderly couple who oh I'm sorry
oh my god I'm telling the end of the
story first
it was a younger couple who they were
talking about how they were very worried
about when their parents passed away the
gentleman's
father was close to passing away the the
the woman's mother her father they were
close to passing away and they felt all
of this anxiety from this hoard of stuff
that they knew was coming down the line
as soon as those people passed away and
you know we kind of gave our advice and
you know told him to have a conversation
with the parents and talked about you
know when when someone dies and they
leave you all their stuff it's yours now
and and they're passed away so you can
do anything you want with that you know
we gave him some good ideas I'm not
gonna sit and unpack that whole answer
we gave him but what really impressed me
about that event is when after that
question was over there was the older
couple who was the elderly couple who
was like oh my god like we were here to
to talk to these guys about how we can
let go of all the hoards of things that
we were holding onto it for our
grandkids the the extra space that we
have when they come over and all of
these things and watching this younger
couple almost like it represented to
them their kids and it and it gave them
this huge revelation of like oh wow like
seeing that younger couple air their
grief to us right about this hoard of
stuff that they're about to get it
helped them see what they were doing to
their own children yeah and I think that
a lot of people in Cheryl's situation
who are 65 years old and they've got all
these things that they want to pass on
down to their kids all these these
trinkets and and watches and whatever
else you know people pass down
they they really need to consider how
their kids feel about it
right so I mean for people in in
Cheryl's situation for 65 years old you
don't know what to do with this stuff
ask your kids now here's the thing
though if you ask your kids you want me
to hang on to this they're probably just
gonna say yes hey you want me to hang on
to this old screw this order your book
shirt do you want me hang on this sure
try giving this stuff away now yes yeah
absolutely because the thing is with I'm
I might say yes I'm gonna store it in
your basement because maybe I wanted
something the moral of the story there
is no one wants your excess no no
because they might say yes I want you to
store it but if you say no okay if you
want that I'm gonna ask you to come and
get it now let's not wait until I die
yeah take this stuff now the question is
are they willing to store it yes
they will need to take up some of their
physical space to store the item because
if they're not they probably don't want
that item that bad now there's always
exceptions to the rules right yes but
but but by-and-large yeah I would I
would encourage people to take that
approach who're who are facing the same
situation to Cheryl now Cheryl is also
having difficulty because you're her
space isn't big enough for having a
bunch of guests over now you can't have
17 kids and and grandkids and all this
other stuff here's here's what I'll say
to that is you can't plan for everything
Cheryl that's why I hotels and Airbnb
exists you have friends who are coming
into town they could stay at the air B&B
right up the street because it's not
gonna happen that much you don't need to
have an abundance of excess space so you
can use it three times a year what you
could do is sell all of that stuff
downsize and then when people come into
town you'll have enough money to pay for
the air B&B that they're gonna be in for
a few nights absolutely I mean imagine
if you Ryan you have a you have a
two-bedroom place now imagine if you're
like well I'm gonna get a three-bedroom
place because and I'm gonna spend you
however much extra it's gonna cost five
hundred bucks a month every month for
the next 12 months we'd spend six
thousand extra dollars just in case
someone wants to come over sometime
imagine where you could do that six
thousand dollars maybe 500 of it is
going to go toward people coming to town
maybe a thousand you just saved $5,000
you don't need all the excess space and
by the way sometimes you can just make
it work we've got some family coming in
June and we don't have enough space for
them so Ella's gonna sleep out on the
couch for a couple days and then Max's
sister and her husband are going to be
in Ella's room and everything's going to
be just fine for a few days now if it's
longer than a few days then guess what
you got to find a hotel but we can make
it work for a couple days and Ella
thinks it's an adventure anyway yeah man
I'm just I just gonna say that the the I
just want to reiterate what I was saying
with with Cheryl situation and to any
parents or grandparents out there who
are holding on to a hoard load of
heirlooms for their for their kids
or they're having extra space don't
assume what your kids want like talk to
your kids about what they want because
if you assume what your kids want then
you're gonna hold on that
absolutely and guess what they they know
they're gonna be honest with you
especially when you're willing to
confront it with now because people
don't want to they're willing that we're
all us people we are willing to put off
today's decisions to tomorrow but if
you're forced to confront it today
that's a type of constraint hey I have
this extra s excess stuff and we need to
deal with it today
now couple options for you here one is
you can take I'm gonna get it out of my
house today so option one is you could
take option two is I'm going to donate
it to one of these three places where
someone else can get value from it right
or option three help me figure out where
else I should go but it's got to leave
my house today that's the constraint or
this week or this month or whatever that
that constraint may be last thing for
Cheryl ask yourself a question what do
you want to fill your life with now I
know you're talking about downsizing and
minimize you getting rid of all the
stuff and I think that's great the
question now is what are you filling
your life with I think that that aching
feeling that you might be feeling right
now but what about when people want to
come to town or what about the the
makeup and the jewelry and uh those are
just things what experiences are you
gonna fill your life with now what are
your values so I'd love to send you a
copy of our book minimalism live a
meaningful life it's our first book and
Ryan and I wrote it about once we got
rid of the stuff what do we fill our
life with we identify what were the the
five foundational values for us in that
book and then how we reshaped our life
refocused our life around those values
how we start our bringing everything
that we did match to all of our daily
activities and actions and priorities
around those five values so Shawn if you
could reach out to Cheryl send her an
audio book version of that if you like
our podcast you'll really like the audio
book it's our shortest book but also you
know what it's available on print and
ebook as well so if Cheryl would prefer
one of those please send her one of
those instead our next question is from
Derek in Indiana
I run appliance repair business they set
a crown point I could pretty much take
my business anywhere I won you know the
main thing that's holding me back from
moving to a better climate is traveling
the world like I want and
being a minimalist like I really want to
be I have wanted to be for quite some
time now is fact that I have the custody
my daughter is her mother lives here by
where I live
I tried brainstorming I come up with
nothing every time and the other
question was basically um you know I've
been minimizing I'm the things and
minimizing on the size of a home and all
that my doing something along the lines
of the tiny homes that just want to know
how people do that with a kid when
you're kid like seven sleepovers and
kids like running around and then of
course winter being a major factor with
them not being able to run around
outside it's cold as hell up here in
Northwest Indiana it's a lot of factors
that seem to be working against
minimalism and seeing the world split
custody thing like I said is the major
thing not being able to move abroad and
pursue my dreams of just you know kind
of backpacking it we got at least seven
years before she's 18 and I can do that
so that's that's the big obstacle there
and if you could help me out here and
give you some brainstorming ideas they
you know I'd be be awesome I appreciate
it
oh and the last thing is I have a leaf
that I haven't so August hmm and that's
another thing hold me back if I'd have
to pay twelve hundred a month to that
okay thank you so seems to me that the
derrick is is constrained by geography
has temporary constraints right now
exactly he has constraints that are that
are imposed on him that he has no
control over so the question that Derek
is asking is I have these constraints I
have no choice of these constraints how
can I do what I want to do given these
constraints and I'll tell you man the
one thing that I made the biggest
mistake of was always telling myself
that my constraints
to me from taking even one step towards
what I wanted to do yes now in in
Derek's question here he talks about how
he wants to travel more he wants to get
out of Indiana and and and live a you
know that peripatetic he wants to be
Colin right he wants to be that type of
minimalist and that's awesome
maybe he's not able to move to a new
country every four months like Lake
Colin had but but right now what he
can't absolutely do is he can still take
a few steps towards that that vagabond
lifestyle that that he wants to live it
could be including his daughter it could
you know I don't know how I'm just
throwing this out there because like you
and Kerry get along really well you and
your ex-wife I don't know how how how
well him and his ex-wife get along but
let's say he wants to go somewhere for a
month or two months so he waits for
summer vacation and he wants to plan a
trip for him and his daughter and the
mother is like oh no you can't bring you
can't pull my daughter away for for two
months that's crazy I'm not gonna be
away from her well maybe you can invite
her to come along and maybe that's a
really stupid idea and and Derek here is
like laughing right now hearing this
like haha she would never come on that
but but I'm just saying thinking along
those those those lines trying to find a
substitute for what he wants to do it's
just not a complete loss here for Derek
yeah I and also I'm going to push back
on Derek's idea of constraints here that
because he said something that really
stuck out to me and that I've been
brainstorming I came up with nothing and
and the the problem with that is quite
often people say I've tried I've tried
everything and I still can't get past my
constraints but if I say oh you've
really you've tried everything well yeah
man everything okay name everything yeah
tell you what just name a thousand
things that you've tried right well no
no I haven't tried a thousand things
that's crazy okay well timber sunette
try one of the hundred things you've
tried I haven't tried a hundred things
to get away from my constraints oh oh so
you've tried how many well I've tried
the same three things over and over and
they haven't worked for me that's the
definition of insanity right there right
and so the the the thing that I
recognize
is that that if you're going to live an
unconventional life which you are which
is what you want Derek the if you want
it enough you'll find a way to make it
happened right I can think of two
examples right off at the top number one
is me I when I first met Bex I was
moving to Los Angeles the month that I
met Rebecca I was I was getting ready to
sign a lease and then I met her I'm like
oh my gosh like I've really liked this
girl I want to see what's gonna happen
so how about I give it a year or two in
Montana although I was done with Montana
I did not want to be there anymore it
was great for that season but I was no
longer happy with that current
constraint but I might add let's try it
out see what happens well when I met
back she had a one-year-old Ella a
brand-new kid right and when we met I
realized like well okay and in her and
her former spouse weren't on the best of
terms they weren't on the worst of terms
either but they certainly weren't on the
best of terms and so I realized like oh
into LA is going to be impossible I'm
brainstorming and I can't think of a
single way I can make this happen but
that's silly right like if you want
something bad enough you'll figure out a
way to to make it work I didn't even
realize like you literally had the same
situation yeah I mean the same exact
this is situation really much I mean it
wasn't although my constraint was 17
years instead of seven his daughter's 11
elbow was one time right right and I'm
like you know I know I'm not gonna stay
in Montana for the next 17 years so I
have an option of staying here and being
not happy about that
or how do I make it as as a static
joyous pleasurable meaningful as
possible the time I'm gonna be here but
also like so that that's what you just
said like okay you've got seven years
and maybe it's less than seven years you
could take steps toward where you want
to go in the meantime but during those
seven years what is your ideal look
light life look like while you're there
not perfect like yeah what does a step
towards your perfect life look like
exactly two steps towards your perfect
life quickly well not even perfect so
for me it's like where ideal life
whatever you want to write so so let's
not let
forget in the way of Derek cuz I think
that's what's happened with Derek right
now is like a perfect life for me would
be traveling the world and dadada
yeah you know what I just want to be
clear no one's life is ever going to be
perfect exactly and so so let's not
aspire toward that let's aspire toward
what's ideal for Derek over the next
seven years and then you start taping
taking steps toward what is ideal and
for me it was those last two years we
were in Montana after being with Becks
was over two years and about two and a
half years I realized like okay like I
can work toward getting to LA now I have
brainstorm I can't think of anything
let's figure this out together I've got
a great support group I've got great
friends people who are supportive how
can I make this work and we put all
kinds of options on the table no idea as
a stupid idea let's put them all on the
table right and what we worked out was
just certainly not but we ended up with
is certainly not perfect but we said
okay for the next year here's what we're
going to try I'm going to be in
California nearly full time Beck's is
going to be 50/50 Montana and California
Ella's gonna come to California once a
month I'm gonna make it back to Montana
once a month that is that's the template
now does it always work that way
no sometimes there are holidays and
custody things or whatever it might be
but that's the template around which
we've built our life for the next year
the next year part is important that's
not how it's going to be for infinity
it's just the next year and then we
continue to reassess is this still
working for us is this the best scenario
is this the most ideal scenario given
the constraints that we have is uh so I
think there's some way like we can use
your situation to help Derek here so the
only difference that I see between your
situation and Derek situation is his kid
is in school right now so he's mine have
you she's in kindergarten no she's in
Montessori School which okay
pre-kindergarten when she starts
attending public schools it tendance is
required a little bit different than a
Montessori School that's true so um have
you guys come up with any solutions on
how to keep her in school and to kind of
make this absolutely so for kindergarten
we found a school that is willing to be
a bit flexible with with her time
yeah and so it's funny just at one point
though I never would have thought of
that man yeah I never would have thought
of trying to find a school that's gonna
be a little bit more flexible with
allowing kids to have time off yeah like
just that as an option I think would
help Derick oh I'm sorry continue well
and it's been I've along the way I have
to be really appreciative of Becks
because she's been willing to go out of
her way to travel quite a bit we so so
we had to move to a smaller apartment in
Montana that her and L are living at um
pretty much full-time Rebecca's there
half the time right and in order to be
able to make it work so it was a smaller
place so it wasn't a tiny house now
Derrick mentioned moving into a tiny
house how do you do that with kids yeah
I wouldn't personally do that with kids
Mariah and I don't have kids and we
wouldn't move to a tiny house but that's
just not what we want to do exactly but
if it is what you want to do you can do
it yeah and it's remember the family we
ran into vexes friend in Australia where
we were in Sydney Sydney what was the
bay we went the beach we went to bondi
bondi beach or something
yeah or just we were trying to get on
Bondi rescue Josh just wanted to give
mouth-to-mouth CPR someone sexy
lifeguard yeah sexy is is a perspectival
term anyway and yeah I'm gonna stop
there but we we met up with a great
family and there are six kids mm-hmm six
kids two parents and they were
caravanning around all of Australia
mm-hmm for the entire year of nine
months and they were the end of that
eight and a half months and talk about a
constraint they're in a RV for nine
months
yeah like a I think an RV is almost like
a tinier home yeah honey er than a tiny
home right it's a tiny home that moves a
tiny home with a steering wheel yeah
with an engine in the steering wheel
right and and so here's the thing there
were some of the most cultured and well
behaved children I'd ever seen never
clear that year had tested them right
and I think any constraints are going to
test you but quite what do we get out of
that testing we get growth from what
and we go through boot camp it's a type
of Tessio as someone in the military is
going through through boot camp and it's
like that's the ultimate sort of testing
right when you do a Navy SEAL testing
that they go through what is so rigorous
but they become the people who make it
out to the other side and even the
people who fail that come out the other
side generally a better person from the
experience so is it possible heck yeah
that's possible but here's the other
thing what's your ideal look like life
look like for the next seven years
Derick but then what is your ideal life
look like once your daughter turns 18
maybe she comes with you for year maybe
she has a gap year and she gets to
travel with you and until then you've
you you you were and because part of the
the fun of an experience is the
anticipatory experience leading up to
the the physical experience itself the
actual travel the immersion the
anticipation is often just as rewarding
as the immersion in fact that's why they
recommend planning vacations well in
advance so you are and you get the joy
of anticipation the entire time
absolutely and Derick when it comes to
the the tiny house man I mean just look
at what is appropriate for your life for
your daughter and for your daughter's
friends that she wants to bring over I
mean Cheryl here she's single 65 a
thousand square foot is her the question
before her perfect size of a house she
said was a thousand square foot that's
what she feels like is enough for her
that's awesome Cheryl has been able to
discover what the the size of her house
needs to be Derek yours doesn't have to
be a thousand square foot it doesn't
have to be 90 square foot it does sound
like what you have right now might be a
little too large that's why I know what
I do when I have something going on in
my life I look at the most extreme
option that is opposite of my current
life but you don't have to go extreme
and if your house is too big that
doesn't mean you have to move into a
tiny house but certainly Derick yes if
moving into a smaller house is gonna
help you do that but don't don't put a
constraint on yourself that is going to
disrupt not just your life but but the
people whose life you are in control
over your daughter's mainly as you know
you don't want to disrupt her life
either so constraints are
great until they start to disrupt your
life yeah that's that's great and or or
disrupt your life disruption can be good
right sure but if they disrupt your life
so much that it caused pain or suffering
that's when it's a problem because maybe
what Derek needs here is a bit of a
disruption because he's living this life
and by the way thank you for doing what
you do I know we've always said that to
like people in the military and stuff
which is great but but he is an
appliance repair person and we
definitely need people like that yes it
keeps us from like oh I'm gonna go out
to you know wherever and buy the new
washer and dryer because this one little
$40 piece broke on this thing and I
don't want to pay for an hour worth of
service no no there are people like you
that that prevent us from consuming
unnecessarily so you're actually doing
some good in the world
while you're waiting to live your most
ideal life but this can also be part of
your life and the last thing that
actually may be two things here we'll
see but the last things that I want to
talk about here is in the meantime let's
say you want to just enjoy your city or
where you're at or maybe it's just long
weekends or if you have split custody
it's week on week off maybe you work
that out and so you can go explore for a
week and then you come back and you live
this and maybe you're like well hi but I
start to work 40 hours a week okay maybe
you have to work 80 hours this week so
you can have next week off and go
explore the world the country go to
Indianapolis even you know explore your
own town and and take advantage of the
current constraints you have because
exploring the Midwest might be the
option for you at the time but man the
Midwest is pretty awesome I know because
we spent the first 31 years of our lives
there and and you can you can explore
within your current constraints last
example there was a Leo Bob Alta I meant
to mention him as well
he's from Guam his family's from Guam he
and his wife have six kids two of which
are from their marriage two of which are
from his ex or hid from his wife's
previous marriage two of which were from
his previous marriage they have six kids
together but it's like a whole Brady
Bunch
right mm-hmm now in order for him to
move to San Francisco and he's written
about this in the past you all know Leo
from our documentary minimalism but also
from his website Zen habits dotnet
encourage you to check that out he's a
great writer but
he has six kids in order for them to all
moved to San Francisco he had to find a
way to convince not just his wife and
their kids to move and make that
appealing to them but make it appealing
to former spouses so they would also
move from Guam to San Francisco man talk
about not not possible I could never do
it I can't come up with anything he made
it happen if Leo can do that with six
kids and former spouses and make it work
then so can you Derrick and I feel
really good about that
what about Derrick - what about
homeschooling because I know that my
sister she started homeschooling my my
dad's kid he him he had one more after
him mmm my mom split up so they were
able to travel she was able to put time
into a couple other programs she wanted
to because she was home-schooled she
started being homeschooled about I think
seventh grade maybe eighth grade I don't
know how viable that is they're just
helping you brainstorm here well Leo
actually does that with someone whose
kids so he gives them the choice of
public school versus I mean they call it
unschooling which is a version of
homeschooling basically and actually
he's written about it
Shaun let's put a link to his
unschooling essay then he wrote about
how he's parenting his kids I think that
will be helpful for Derrick's we'll put
that in the show notes for you as well
Derrick last thing I'd love to send you
as a copy of our book everything that
remains it's a story of well it's a
story of prioritization in a way because
we had these supposedly ideal lives in a
world with priorities gone wild our next
documentary priorities gone wild Joshua
Ryan visits South Beach then the flash
is - like an image of you in a thong
bikini of course walking down south
anyway it is a story of prioritization
because Ryan I had these perfect lives
ostensibly perfect from the outside but
it certainly was not ideal that's
because our priorities were out of whack
and and really what we're talking to you
about
today Derek is what are your priorities
and then how can we really how can we
really make sure that we want those
priorities enough how can we get enough
leverage and everything that remains is
the story of that five year journey of
letting go of our current lives of the
life of excess and consumerism and and
status and supposed success and walking
toward a more a more fulfilling life a
life that was filled with good habits
and routines and meaningful
relationships and creativity and also
involved moving and touring and seeing
the country and traveling more than we
ever had but also being grounded in what
in the people that we wanted to be and
so I think you'll find a lot of value in
everything that remains Derek will put a
link to that in the show notes but if
you could send him an audio book version
of that or a book book or ebook if if
that's what he wants and we'll send
those off to you all right if you're
listening to this and with him of course
we'd love to hear what you have to say
so if you have a comment or a tip about
constraints or restraint Bex and I are
always looking for good sex toy advice
or if you have any advice for any of our
callers today then leave us a voicemail
for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also email
a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm will air our favorite
comments and tips at the end of a future
episode including the end of this
episode as well there you can stay tuned
for comments and tips from our listeners
as well Ryan what time I said you know
what time it is Josh it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we were on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists turn the lightning around
Ryan and I each do our best to answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's and the show notes so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our quotes in one
place
minimal Maxim's calm thank you to jess
for curating our thousand plus quotes
over there at minimal Maxim's calm
alright our first question is from
Chiara what constraints have you
implemented in your life to help your
life as a minimalist well I
like to this question because it was a
very broad question so it allowed me to
give a broad tweetable answer here I
know it's fun I love the broad questions
for that reason to man because because
me a broad answers yes or you can get
really detailed if you want to to so you
have all you have a plethora of options
here right so her question really
allowed me to read
define minimalism in a way and I've been
struggling with this for three or four
years now ever since meeting Ella
who will be turning five this month god
help us all
because she'll say what is minimalism
and like I've tried to explain
explaining minimalism to a four-year-old
and a two-year-old especially when she
was - trying to explain it to her was
difficult but it's helped me sort of
sort of work out my material in front of
how do I yeah how do I explain this in a
way that everyone can understand it and
I think this is one way maybe a
four-year-old isn't gonna understand but
I think this is another way to think
about minimalism so my short answer is
this chiara minimalism is a life of well
curated constraints so some constraints
are good too many constraints might be
bad but if we curate our constraints we
choose our constraints carefully well
then we're gonna live a well lived life
absolutely ma'am
Kyra here's what I'd say every impulse
is a potential pothole on the road to a
meaningful life so you know what
constraints do I have they they really
they really are geared towards my
impulses I if I didn't have constraints
on TV I'd sit there and drool on myself
and I would just sit there and watch
reruns of the office and Seinfeld and
friends and all the other shows that I
love to drool drool - there's a lot of
drooling yeah you're a fan of drooling -
I drew a lot of attention ruling calm
Brian's new blog but you know it's funny
just to think about so we're talking
about how constraints can help people
live a meaningful life but there are
there are constraints we could put on
ourselves that will prevent us from
living a meaningful life and I think
giving in to every
pulse we have that is the biggest
constraint that we could have when it
comes to living a meaningful life does
that make sense yeah so what you're
saying is that if we act on impulse
we're acting like a child even we're
gonna run out in traffic we're gonna
we're gonna drive grandma's suburban
around the neighborhood and crash into
cars and because what was the other
thing that kids said in that video and
he said it's fun to do bad thing yeah
yeah I guess what it's fun to do bad
things and and and that's ultimately
what you're saying yeah it's fun to do
bad things but bad things don't ever
lead to a meaningful life it's the
opposite it's a life of impulse it's not
a meaningful life all right our next
question is from Joshua hook he's been
he's been on fire with these question I
was gonna say Minnesota all right Joshua
Hook how can we determine what
constraints are in our best interests I
know for me I have a tendency to dislike
constraints and chafe against them even
if they are in my best interests so my
short answer to that is constraints are
useful only when they increase our
freedom yeah we were just talking about
how too many constraints can absolutely
prevent us from living a meaningful life
right right we don't want to just
deprive ourselves of TV or deprive
ourselves of whatever it may be that's
interfering with our life just for the
sake of deprivation right unless you
just do have a short-term exert so I'll
talk real quick Joshua will hook about
some of the things I've let go of
sometimes I will put up a temporary time
period so a few of the things that the
sort of magic tricks that I've done is
as a minimalist or becoming a minimalist
I got rid of TV for nine years and then
we moved into this new apartment in Los
Angeles and they had the previous tenant
left this giant TV on the wall and now I
feel like okay I've over the last nine
years shaped a habit around that
constraint so I can bring it back into
my life more intentionally fact we watch
Westworld on it last night which was
which was a great TV show and but we we
do appointment viewing now we don't just
sit down and binge watch stuff now I got
rid of my cell phone for two months and
I brought it back into my life finally I
realized like that constraint was
deprivation
and I realized like when I bring it back
in I can use it differently I don't have
to have Twitter and Instagram and email
on my phone but I can use it to make
phone calls or send text messages or GPS
or listen to podcast or listen to music
or however I want to use the phone but
use it in a more intentional way so
sometimes those constraints help us
temporary constraints help us identify
how to use our things our tools in a
more intentional way also a few other
things that I got rid of home internet
for five years and that made me more
productive but also reshape to my habits
in a way that I didn't expect and we've
written about all these things on the
website so Shawn if you can put a link
to the at least those three things I
just talked about there last thing I got
rid of another constraint I put in my
life I got rid of goals and I did that
for a hundred days and in fact I didn't
even do it for a hundred days at first
our friend Leo Bob Alta he wrote about
it and so I said oh I'm gonna give up
goals for 100 days because but I'm gonna
goals I don't know how for how long
because I don't want it to be a goal and
that constraint help me realize that the
work we put in our standards are much
greater than our expectations our
standards get us farther than our
expectations do and so those are a few
constraints maybe living without goals
for a period of time is a type of
constraint that will better serve your
creativity or what you want to
accomplish it makes me think about this
gentleman I was I was doing a podcast
interview at this festival back in
February right before we took off for
Australia but after the podcast
interview this gentleman came up to me
and he was like dude you know I really
am a fan of your you know documentary
and and and I love the podcast and stuff
he's like I just need some advice on as
a musician like what do I do
- how do I use minimalism to help me be
a better musician and I was like well
what do you see as your problem right
now he's like well I'd know how to play
guitar I know how to play this
instrument that instrument the bongos
that I'm like which one are you an
expert at oh I'm not an expert in any of
them I guess I just have to play all of
them I'm like okay I was like do you
like to sing he's like oh yeah man I
love to sing it's like okay why don't
you see what you can do with your voice
just use your voice and then he's like
oh yeah and I'm like and if there's
another instrument
you need to bring in to bring in that
instrument yeah like slowly introducing
things yeah yeah it reminded me this
metaphor just popped in my head diving
deep on one thing we know there are
people who are deep-sea divers mm-hmm
I've never heard of a wide sea diver
that's really good man yeah it's
absolutely true man aye aye aye aye aye
aye but I was really encouraged to hear
say say like yeah man you know what I'm
gonna stop playing all my instruments
for a month and just use my voice and he
was like if I feel like I need to bring
in another instrument after this month
I'll do that yeah he's like but if I'm
you know get some really good stuff
going with my voice and I feel good
about that
I'm just gonna continue using my voice
but just the perfect example of how yeah
you throw a little constraint on there
and you start to think of every
situation a little bit differently
that's definitely helpful constraint my
Maia my answer to you is this Joshua
hook continuously avoiding things we
dislike stunts our growth yes yeah so
he's talking about how he has a he has a
tendency to dislike constraints and he
avoids them essentially is what he's
saying if you avoid everything that you
dislike you're probably probably gonna
live a pretty banal life yeah and you're
gonna feel probably like you're not
living the most meaningful life possible
yeah if you nerf your world you're never
going to develop the calluses necessary
to create something meaningful damn that
was pithy Sean you better write that one
down all right we have one more question
here this question is from Sivan ISA
Vani asks how can there be an upside to
constrain all I say is give me loads of
money so I can find out if it truly
doesn't work now what Cervantes alluding
to here is in our documentary Jim Carrey
has a quote in there so everyone knows
money doesn't buy happiness but everyone
wants to try it out for themselves just
to find out right and okay we have a
really good answer I think I have a good
answer for this will expand on a lot but
if you want to hear my answer and Ryan's
answer to that question you can listen
to this week's post script episode over
at the minimalist private podcast which
is exclusive to our patreon supporters
that's that's why it's private so if you
want to support our show and if you want
to help keep this podcast a hundred
percent advertisement free then head on
over to the minimal
komm support also in addition to our
weekly PostScript episodes which we put
up every Wednesday the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our
monthly ask the minimalists anything
episode so we interact with our patreon
supporters and they can ask us literally
anything they want also unreleased
recordings of all of our live events in
fact we're putting up sydney this month
and I think Ryan your favorite event of
the whole tour last year was probably
Melbourne got Melbourne
yeah Melbourne the first of all the
first melon was my favorite only because
the one gal in there was just hilarious
yeah I mean she was just like and our
answer was was so good oh my gosh in
fact there would be a really funny title
for that episode that I can't say right
now but how about we do Melbourne
exclusively toe up for our patreon
supporters next month okay because each
month we were putting out these live
events just for our patreon supporters I
know that was your favorite we already
put out my favorite episode live episode
mine was from Edmonton last year which
is on our main feed oh I'd say you were
talking about our from the Australian
leg the that first Melbourne was stopped
was definitely my favorite what was your
favorite Australian stop my favorite
Australian stop was probably Sydney yeah
so which we put out this one so if you
want recordings of all of our live
events that goes also goes up in the
minimalist private podcast feed and Oh
once you become a supporter you also
receive a personal link to that podcast
feeds so it shows up right there in your
podcast player or whatever you're
listening to this podcast on right now
so you don't have to get on the internet
and and log into some website every
single time you want to listen to this
it shows up right there on your phone
regularly just if you're a supporter of
the show and also as a patreon supporter
you also receive access to our monthly
live stream videos as well as first
access to tickets to all of our live
events before those tickets are
available to the public and the entire
back catalogue of all of our past
private podcast episodes you can find
all the details and good stuff over at
the minimalists comm slash support and
if you want a little snippet here's a
snippet from this week's PostScript
episode
I am all for money money helps us it's
as a resource just like time as a
resource attention as a resource
relationships can be a resource in our
life the the assets physical goods are
all resources the question is how do we
use those resources and if we are
irresponsible with the few resources we
have we don't have a lot of money and
we're irresponsible with that little bit
of money what are we gonna do when we
get a lot of money it's going to amplify
our irresponsibility we're going to be
less responsible with more money and how
do I know this because all of my 20s
that's exactly what I did
I grew up really poor realize well at
least thought I realized that oh we're
not happy because we don't have any
money so let's go make some money I went
out and got the entry-level corporate
sales job started making good money and
the better money the better money but I
so always spent more money than I made I
was irresponsible it turns out the
reason I was discontented growing up is
I made that well my family made bad
decisions with a few resources resources
we had and then I continued to amplify
those bad decisions with more money
however now that we are in our 30s and
moving toward 40 money has become a
resource with which we can do good
[Music]
all right and we're back and if you want
to hear that full conversation you can
become a patron over at the minimalists
comm okay now it's time for our added
value portion of the show this is where
we each talk about something that has
added value to our lives recently Ryan
what's added value to your life recently
oh dude I got one of those new albums
that are old to recommend to you one of
those old new album yeah the new old
album I think it's old new album okay
it's new to me
aha no there's a band called milky
chance a group you said it might be one
guy I don't really know it like one or
two guys I think it's one or two guys I
accidentally went to one of their
concerts mhm I was at South by Southwest
and 2015 did you like it I loved the
show and I know that the hit song they
have I forget the title of that first
big hit that they had and the live show
with solid man nice no they have a I
think it's from last year they have an
album called blossom the people are
probably listening to me right now like
duh
yeah that's an awesome album but if you
haven't heard of this album I just found
it again like just from listening to
like picking a radio station or a
playlist and then the song comes on and
I'm like oh who's this band and then I
look him up and like they've been around
forever
right yeah have you guys heard the
Rolling Stone oh my god so many awesome
hits I have three things that have added
value to my life but they all sort of
pertained this this idea of constraints
one is a constraint I've added to my
under myself that has improved my sleep
significantly over the last few months
and I know because sometimes I slip up
and I don't put this constraint on
myself and it hurts my sleep so I dunno
liquids after 5:00 p.m. I don't drink
any liquids out of five pm some days I
try to push it as close to 3 p.m. as
possible now I fully hydrates why I just
have to take a bathroom break
Podcast shawn such a good editor you
don't even know that I just took a
bathroom break a moment ago in fact I'm
peeing my pants right now huh no anyway
so I I I stopped drinking liquids after
5 p.m. and I went on to get up in the
middle of the night and use the bathroom
right and for me for whatever
I'll tweet the other day and said I just
turned 40 and without my congratulations
my bladder is now the size of a shot
glass
yeah and I'm since I'm steamrolling
towards 40 for whatever reason I feel
like I always had to get up in the
middle night and pee and and so now I
don't want if I don't drink any liquid
so it's a constraint that improves my
life but throughout the day I'm
constantly drinking a ton of water up
until then so I make sure I'm not
dehydrated I drink a lot of water and it
forces me to just have a window of
constraint where I'm staying fully
hydrated so that's one constraint that
has certainly added value to my life
helped me sleep better one other
recommendation or just things that if
I'd in my life Matt carnies new album
just came out yeah and the reason that
it's called crazy talk mm-hmm and the
reason that I mean it's been out kind of
sort of it's been out yeah he was
putting out one song at a time for a
while LA he put out what five or six
singles before the album came out I
think it's 13 tracks now he has a
beautiful cover of Shaw day my mom he
still has this in the Shaw day when we
were growing up and he does a great
cover of one of Shaddai songs but the
whole album is great but the reason
constraints came to mind with this album
crazy talk is this is his first
independent release so he left his major
record label he built a studio in his
own house he doesn't have the big budget
in fact yeah I read one of his best
albums ever man absolutely and that's
that's the point so he I read this
article he said I'm for my first album
nothing nothing left to lose
he said that was independent right no no
read the record company spent $250 under
$50,000 just on the video oh wow
the first video to the first singles to
150 thousand he said I don't spend that
much on recording and marketing the
entire album now you know company
recommends to spend millions of dollars
to make albums like this but now he has
his own tiny recording studio at his
house and he's independent and he's made
this album with those constraints has
actually made the album better and he's
evolved to the thing I love about
McCartney's music is it's always in FATA
Kaleem at kearney but it always reflects
a time period within his life he's
somehow
simultaneously and paradoxically stays
true to his sound while his sound
evolves it it sounds like that's
impossible but he does it it's like he
doesn't take a such a far leap that were
like we're Dylan went electronic or
whatever but he progresses enough that
it's far away from his previous album
that each album is its own body of work
has its own sound and I think the
constraints on this album in particular
made the album more contemporary but
also forced him to get more creative
with the fewer resources that he had
that totally reminds me about I think a
recommended Frank Turner not too long
ago his full album just came out either
today or yesterday I was so happy
because like the new way that the
release and Records manages or albums
that drives me crazy right yeah well I
mean it's it's very singles driven which
people think is new but it's actually
that's a 60s and 70s and 50s thing right
people just thought it was all you know
7-inch singles and now we're in a weird
way gone back to the 7-inch it's up it's
a 4-inch phone yeah upon which we listen
to these these endless singles right and
because also there's a lot of talk about
a constraint fewer resources go into
making a single and you can make a
hundred singles and if one of them hits
all of a sudden you're touring for two
years off of that one single right now
personally I'm more of an album guys and
I know you you're an album guy as well
Ryan so check out crazy talk from Matt
Carney we'll put a link to that in the
show notes and last but not least since
we're talking about constraints to me
the best constraint there is is honesty
so honesty is the best constraint
there's a great book called lying by Sam
Harris so take an hour to read in fact
if you listen to it on audiobook it's an
hour and 15 minute audio book and that's
with a Q&A he does at the end of it so
it's like having a podcast episode
basically it's one of the the most
concise and and clearly written screeds
about why not to lie under any
circumstance and unless lying has become
self-defense but then of course it's not
lying you know if you're someone's at
your door and there are murderer and you
know are you home you're not gonna say
well yes I'm home please kill me but but
he gives you an example even around
things that are controversial like Santa
Claus and he he presents a great answer
as to why not to lie to your kids about
Santa Claus but how you can still
present the myth of Santa Claus in a way
that's what we do with Ella
in fact you you've seen this because we
went down to Rodeo Drive this year with
Ella and like she sat on Santa's lap she
believes Santa's real even though I tell
her he's not real and we explained what
she saw him at the mall that's what she
says to me I said I said but but I'm
like but you know Santa's just made of
it she's a guy in a costume she goes no
Josh I I saw him at the mall yeah but
it's the man that costume I said if I
dressed up like Peppa Pig would I be
Peppa Pig she's like well no so that's
that that's what some people do that
dress up like Santa Claus she goes okay
but I saw him at the mall so no I mean I
make sure that I've never lied to Ella
and and it's one of the things I'm most
proud of because I know that if I want
her to be able to trust me then I can't
lie about some things and then expect
she's going to believe me
with respect to other things right
sometimes telling the truth is difficult
but Sam Harris presents some ways in
that book lying and it's a fact I bought
it for a friend who's going through a
tough time with with some experiences
that he's had recently and it just made
me go back and re-listen to the
audiobook version because Bex had never
listened to it we were we were driving
out to Joshua Tree this weekend she
found a lot of value in it as well it
was the first book of Sam Harris she had
been exposed to and I think it's a great
place to start with with his work as
well all right let's move on to right
here right now so we talked about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalists
well we have a photo of our new podcast
studio up on our Instagram page if you
want to check that out we'll put a link
to that in the show notes so we're just
at the minimalists on Instagram and we
have a photo tour I'm sorry a video tour
of the new podcast
do coming soon on patreon for our
patreon supporters since this is you
find folks who have helped us build this
new podcast studio and are funding the
soon to be video version of this podcast
so if you want to subscribe to the video
version of this podcast just head on
over to youtube.com slash the
minimalists also I'm teaching a writing
class coming up June 24th just twice a
year I do a two hour workshop on how to
write better so most of you know I I
teach a four week writing class online
and you can check that out over at how
to write better org but I know some of
you don't have the the resources or the
time the money or the attention to spend
four weeks on a writing class so what I
try to do is tweeze out some of my
favorite ingredients from that four-week
class and make it so you can at least
get started on how to write better how
to improve your writing after this
2-hour workshop it's a standalone
independent workshop and you can find
that over at the minimalists comm slash
workshop it's called how to write better
two hour workshop and what we'll do is
it's a live workshop but if you can't
attend a live version we'll have the the
video available afterwards you you'll
have access and perpetuity to the the
recorded video but if you are on that
workshop we'll also be doing a Q&A at
the end of it so I can answer some of
your writing questions that's June 24th
the minimalists comm slash workshop and
if you want to receive any new writings
on our website or if you want to get the
show notes the always hear us talking
about at the end of every episode then
we'll send those right to your email
inbox just go to the minimalists comm
and your email address at the top we'll
also send you any news about our new
documentary that we're working on once
we have more details about that also any
new tour stops that we announce in the
future or events that we have with the
minimalists live then you will be one of
the first people to know over at the
minimalists comm and your email address
there will never send you any spam or
anything you don't want though because
that stuff's gross Brian you got
anything else for us finally here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners
hi my name is Nina from Little Rock
Arkansas and this is regarding your
school's episode I really enjoy
listening to this episode as a parent of
two soon-to-be school-aged kids I have
found myself for researching educational
options and came across homeschooling
and how statistically homeschooled kids
learn better because there are less
stressors that are associated with what
we know as traditional education there
is more flexibility with pursuing
personal interests as well as the
ability to learn at the child's pace
rather than preparing for exams since I
am an active-duty military member I have
had the option to pass my GI bill to my
kids so they have secured funds to
attend college that they choose to do so
but if they don't attend I have come to
the realization that I am okay with that
as long as I am able to cultivate a
lifelong desire to learn I feel I would
have met my intent my mindset on college
has shifted as well considering that
emotional intelligence is far more
valuable than a degree than a degree
like you said in the podcast how many
people have degrees and how many attend
college for the social reasons life
itself is a classroom with such an
emphasis on academics a lot of soft
skills are not developed and I have
found through homeschooling options
there is a development of the whole
child not just academically so those
soft skills are developed exponentially
because they are learning via real-life
interactions not a classroom environment
as my husband and I approach retirement
from the military we have agreed to
prepare for a less hectic and less
stressful life into home school and
possibly world school and learn from the
very real world that we have around us
hi I recently had a little accidental
discovery about decluttering and kids
and toys and I know you guys get asked
about that all the time so I thought it
might be helpful if I shared my
experience as a rule of thumb I really
haven't done much or don't do much with
my kids with minimalism I try to you
know show them model for them and talk
to them about you know why I have less
stuff for the decisions we make about
things in our house but I haven't
declared them in any real way I've sort
of resigned myself to living with kid
clutter however about a month ago we had
some work done on the house and we got
dust everywhere including all over their
toys and I so I took all their toys to
the basement with the intention of
cleaning them off and bringing them back
up I didn't have a ton of time right
then so I initially just cleaned off a
couple of their favorites I brought them
back and just told the kids that you
know their toys were coming and that if
they needed any toys in the meantime if
there's anything particularly wanted
they could ask me for it and I would go
clean it off and bring it to them that
was about a month ago and I have
occasionally been asked for a toy here
there but for the most part 80% of their
toys have been in the basement and
they're not bored and they're not
complaining and there's a lot less
clutter in the house and they might have
even learned something so I had an
accidental packing party with my kids
toys and it worked
hi my name's Eloise I'm from Melbourne
Australia I wanted to thank you very
much for touching on food and its
association with minimalism I've
struggled for many many many years with
an eating disorder and have been
recovering now for about two years and
it's is about the same time same amount
of time that I've been investing my
energy into minimalism so today when I
was listening to your podcast I realized
just how big of an impact minimalism has
had on my ability to recover from
bulimia and I sat down after listening
to the podcast and I made a really long
list about how it has positively
impacted my recovery and it's long but
the most prominent thing I can think of
is being more aware of the waste the
waste the wasted time the wasted energy
the wasted food the wasted thought
processes I've wasted so much of my life
on my eating disorder and your podcast
has helped me purge the things from my
life that led me to feel overwhelmed and
out of control and those were the things
that led me to my eating disorder
alright Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening we'll see you next time
and minimus